عاملان الديان الى انخفاض متوسط العمر
المتوقع في الولايات المتحده العام الماضي
الى ادنى مستوياته منذ عام
1996 الاول ظهور فيروس كورونا والثاني
تناوله جرعه زائده من المواد المخدره
مراكز السيطره على الامراض والوقايه منها
اوضحت ان هذا التراجع بدا بشكل متواصل عام
2020 حين ظهر فيروس كورونا ما يطرح
تساؤلات حول تداعيات ظهور متحورات جديده
منه خاصه في ظل موجه الثلوج والصقيع
الحليليه
اكيد يا وقت اللي صار هل طلع الكوفين اثر
على الناس اثر على البوم اثر على السكري
تبعهم الناس اللي ما صار تاثروا منه فهذا
اثر الاعمار ال ال لايف باند تبع الناس
هنا في امريكا الدنيا كلها وهذه هذه كانت
نتائج
وما قد يفاقم الوضع بالنسبه لفايروس
كورونا في الولايات المتحده وفق خبراء
التسييس المستمر لمواجهه الفيروس بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين بشان تلقي
اللقاحات والجرعات المعززه واجراءات
الوقايه ما اثر سلبا على قرارات
الامريكيين وزاد نسبه وفيات المصابين
الامور هذه كارثه كبيره انا بعتها السياسه
ما لازم تتدخل في الطب اطلاقا اولا
والثانيه لازم وزاره الصحه وعندك كمان
السي دي سي لازم تكون موجود بطريقه ملموسه
اكثر اما بالنسبه للوفياتي بالجرعه
الزائده فقد زادت عام 2021 بالنسبه 16%
تقريبا مقارنه بعام 2020 وفقه مراكز
السيطره على الامراض البيانات الجديده
تظهر ان معدل عمر الاطفال المولودين عام
2001 في الولايات المتحده 76 عاما واربعه
اشهر بينما كان المعدل مولودين عام 2019
ثمانيه وسبعين عاما وثمانيه اشهر حسين
الطود العربيه واشنطن